well Canada the parent company of CTV
News is cutting 1300 jobs CTV News is
reporting on itself now with a smaller
team behind and in front of the camera
the six percent cut at Bell Media its
parent company Bell Media is shedding
hundreds of positions and letting go of
some of Canada's best-known journalists
so far they say senior reporters in the
Ottawa Bureau have been laid off nearly
all CTV foreign correspondents are gone
and its presence in Washington reduced
CTV has some really experienced
hard-working talented journalists who
Canadians have come to rely on Bell
Media is also scaling back local news
closing six radio stations and selling
three others I was blindsided the
layoffs came after a high profile exit
last summer when former CTV National
anchor Lisa leflam was abruptly ousted
the company says it can't afford its
current operations after a drop in
viewers and profits in an open letter
the president of Bell Canada writes the
company expects to lose more than 250
million dollars in Legacy phone revenues
per year while its news operations incur
40 million dollars in annual operating
losses the media segment has been
underperforming and so I think that
we're going to see more moves that are
reflective the Liberals tabled Bill c-18
to try to level the playing field
requiring Tech giants like Facebook and
Google to pay news organizations for
repurposing their content most of the
advertising is going to a few big
players like Facebook and and Google
that bill is still before the Senate but
with the news landscape shrinking media
experts warn Canadian democracy is in
danger you're missing the accountability
and you're missing just a sense of the
things you need to know if you want to
be an Engaged citizen while Bell County
has its Revenue in New
zillion dollars in
the calling it a solid start to the year
esri Global News Ottawa